years ago they really tried to push the
softer gentler Kinder view of guys and
romance novels and they didn't sell them
and my guess is they didn't sell well
because even if in your daily life it
might be easier to have a guy that would
do whatever you wanted no matter what
that might not be what you fantasize
about
did you recently do a study about
reactions to jizz on the face porn
stimuli
I did I did do a study on that in fact I
actually have just completed a follow-up
study as well so it's all about [ __ ]
shots these days
what is what's all about come show is
your life all about [ __ ] shots
[Music]
that's what my life is all about [ __ ]
shots I mean but certainly lately it has
seemed to be the topic of conversation
if you tell somebody you're doing that
that's what they want to hear about
okay I I want to hear about it please
tell me everything
sure I mean part of the reason for being
interested in it is because for a long
time there has been
um I think a lot of claims about the
nature of pornography
um that it's about degrading women
um that uh you know it has all these
negative connotations right and there
are a bunch of different researchers
who've assessed this in different kinds
of ways but one sort of theme that has
run through things is the idea that an
external ejaculation that is deposited
on on the face is seen as being
degrading or seen in a negative light
and there's a number of ways that you
can actually
think about that and a number of years
ago I read
um a chapter in a book that made me
really think about this and the chapter
had a line in it about how what makes
coming
on somebody's body degrading and coming
inside them sacred
you know like okay
okay that's not necessarily a bad point
why do we have such a focus on it as
being a negative thing and what does it
really mean that it is so ubiquitous in
pornography that it's really difficult
to find pornography in fact where you
won't see a scene like that somewhere in
the film and so we decided to do a study
where we would actually show people
um faces that had had deposits made on
them and asked them about how arousing
or how degrading they found those images
to be and how much they like the
pictures
and we actually had subjects not our own
students because
um our own students can be fragile but
we recruited adults from the general
population to do this and so we had
people look at um faces that we varied
right so they some of them look well
they all looked at the same faces but
they either looked at faces that were
male faces or female faces right we
looked at and so because we were also
interested in the sexual orientation of
people and how that might influence this
so we had them look at male faces and
female faces and we also varied them in
terms of their reaction so whether the
person looked happy about having a
[ __ ] on their face or whether they
looked neutral about it or whether they
looked very unhappy about it
um and so as you might expect
um from if you have sort of review that
that that
uh men like it when their partners are
enjoying what's going on men watching
these images generally preferred the
faces where the females actually look
like they were enjoying the experience
um whether they were male or female
faces that they were looking at there
definitely is also an effect of the
preferred sets so for men straight men
don't really like looking at pictures of
other men
ejaculate on their face
they um were not so happy with those
they were their least preferred photo
for them as the one uh with guys that
had come on their face but homosexual
Men actually that was their favorite
um photo of them not surprising right
um for women it was actually interesting
the women who so women in general didn't
like the images as much but for the
women if you looked at them across their
sexual orientation bisexual women
actually like the images a little bit
more than either heterosexual or lesbian
women which was also kind of interesting
and might actually have more to say
about what shapes bisexuality
um than than anything else some sort of
openness to experience type thing maybe
exactly that it might be a sort of
general interest in sex
um and a more sort of sexual exploration
kind of thing that that's influencing
that and that's why they had those views
when you looked at the men it was much
more linear uh in terms of the
relationship
um in terms of like okay so gay guys
preferences were here and straight guys
were like oh my god
um the women it was actually looked like
a little top hat so it was a little bit
of a different kind of picture so
um and we were interested in other
things too like weather disgust
sensitivity would play a role if people
are really worried about pathogens maybe
they would be less likely to like such
images and it did have an effect
um you know in general people who are
very high on pathogen avoidance are not
as keen on bodily fluids especially near
the face
um and we also
um
found a few other things that mattered
including sociosexuality which shouldn't
be surprising in general people who are
more permissive in their sexual
attitudes are more interested in
short-term mating also enjoyed the
images more
so we for the most part we found the
sorts of things that we were kind of
hoping to find
um in terms of the results
um
at least in terms of going back to that
idea about what makes it
disgusting or degrading versus sacred it
seems like somebody enjoying it makes it
a positive experience right for the
person that was the biggest effect I
give you partial diet what was the
factor that had the biggest impact was
whether she liked it and what the sexual
orientation was in terms of matching to
the person that was the recipient
what do you think is the difference
between something inside and something
on the face
um
horn you put things outside
um even though they started inside
um it is largely because it's a real
visual obvious sign like you know for
sure the guy came because it's all over
her face
um if he comes inside her unless you're
doing a close-up shot of you know some
of it dribbling out you're not really
getting the same you know proof of
ejaculation I suppose so I think that
could have some something to do with why
it's so ubiquitous I mean why it's on
the face I think there's probably
I mean I think there's probably a couple
different things including that men like
to look at women's faces
shocker I know but men do like to look
at women's faces and also the face shows
that it's an individual woman like a
different woman and so if men are often
attracted to
um novel women or a variety of women
spaces convey information about
different differences between different
women right and that may also be
appealing like just like think about
porn and seeing lots of different women
being extra arousing as compared to just
one woman that you might get used to
I have so kind of like the Coolidge
effect yes I had Louise Perry on the
show a case against the sexual
Revolution a couple of maybe a few
months ago she said in that a lot of
women she thinks uh sometimes
misinterpret rough sex as being this
um I want you so much that I will do
anything to have you uh 50 Shades of
Gray style thing
I'm not sure whether that's backed up in
the literature and we can go into that
in a second however the same sort of
um I will overcome my programming around
being gentle around women because this
is how passionate you have driven me to
be by men that seems to be at least part
of a motivation that I could imagine
maybe women have in the back of their
minds right that there is something
going on there what I'm wondering with
the come on the face situation is
whether or not it's this kind of the
same in Reverse this is something that's
quite porcelain and sacred and beautiful
it's something that women take great
care of and I am so turned on by you
that I'm happy for you to desecrate it
yeah I mean that could be part of it I
mean I think I mean when we think about
the things that people do together
sexually a huge part of it is doing
things that your partner likes and
hopefully you both like doing the same
things right that's going to lead to a
more satisfying sexual relationship over
time but I think that there are times
when people may do things specifically
because they please their partner and if
your partner really likes doing that
maybe you do that more often I mean
there's also the question about how
often people do that in their everyday
sex at home versus how much they get off
on watching it in pornography as well
logistically logistically a more
difficult way to convene the end of your
your evening
in a Messier way right like I mean not
everybody wants to but everyone's got
time to wash their hair not everyone's
got time to wash their hands exactly you
know I mean it's it I think there are
just practicalities that make some
things different in your everyday life
that are different than important I
would agree I would agree we don't all
go and fight Thanos every day either for
presumably the same reason so I found
the other day an article by Patricia
Sanchez in scipost.org rough sex
associated with novelty seeking but not
aggression rough sex is usually
associated with aggression but new
research published in Evo s journal the
Journal of evolutionary studies
Consortium found that engaging in rough
sex may be more indicative of novelty
seeking than aggressive tendencies rough
sexual behaviors have been thought of as
sexual aggression for decades but Recent
research shows that rough sex may be
more so recreational and consensual by
both parties rough sexual behaviors have
been shown to increase in situations
that involve male jealousy and being
separated from a sexual partner this is
in quotes while these analyzes provide
clues as to what motivates or triggers
rough sexual behavior several questions
remain enhancered jealousy may be one
motivated for men but sex was reportedly
desired and initiated by both sexes so
what the motivators are for both sexes
are particularly for women remains
unexplored
what are your thoughts on that Catherine
um
I thought someone understood it it
sounds familiar
um but I think there so you in terms of
the sort of I'd explore the what's
driving women to initiate rough sex or
to be interested in it I think there
could be a couple different things one
of them is actually what you were
alluding to before this issue about
the idea that you're that a guy may want
you so badly be so passionately in love
with you that he is not as careful as he
might otherwise be and you know there's
a long history of women finding that at
least appealing in their fantasy lives
if you think about romance novels and
bodice Ripper romances I mean they're
all about the guy not being able to
control himself and and like I will die
if I don't have you kind of thing
um and the idea that somebody could be
that incredibly devoted to you I think
is appealing to women who are often very
interested in commitment right and the
idea that you would have that kind of
power over another individual in that
sense I think is appealing so I think
that that could be part of it
um there's also
um you know been this sort of idea
tossed around that it could be similar
to
um
what we see in some other animal species
where females will
um require males to demonstrate their
own sort of physical prowess and so my
favorite example when talking about with
students is what we call the bump test
and so this is something that happens in
Gladiator frogs and so Gladiator fries
will approach a female frog and she will
actually be aggressive towards him and
if he runs away she won't mate with him
but if he's pushy back then she'll
actually have sex with him right so
she's like selecting for sort of
aggressive and physical strength on the
part of the male frog right and so
there's this idea that maybe females are
doing that you know unconsciously in
humans sometimes and they may be
initiating this because they actually
are you know taking some sort of reward
or pleasure in testing male ability to
demonstrate their strength right in the
same way that women might enjoy watching
men compete in different kinds of
physical Sports
um because again it's sort of showing
off prowess
that makes sense it's the closest I
suppose that a woman could get to
experiencing a man's physical strength
kind of all uh brought to bear on her
yeah yeah I think it's like if you
imagine the sort of the kinds of some of
the kinds of things that are that that
are in that assessment of rough sex
right it would include things like
wrestling right and sort of that kind of
play fighting and overpowering kind of
thing and yeah it is it's typically
going to be the closest thing that you
would experience to that and so it is a
way of sort of trying to assess that and
in a playful way not really a
threatening way
hmm what about the novelty seeking but
not aggression thing
It's associated with it so in the study
there were a bunch of different
questions that asked them about what
kinds of things and experiences do you
find associated with your experiences of
rough sex whether it's a male or a
female initiating it and one of the
things that popped out was this idea
about trying it because it's something
different it's something new we were
bored
um you know we saw in in a movie you
know different things like that being
indicators and it was correlated with a
bunch of other things that are
associated with novelty seeking like
having sex in public places
um engaging in
um sex with sex toys things like that so
it seemed to be more about novelty than
about aggression in terms of like
having negative feelings about the
person that you're being aggressive
towards
um and the one sort of one that that was
also in there that that
um that we talked about that is it's
interesting because it kind of has a
little bit of overlap is this issue
about sexual jealousy that when men may
be experiencing sexual jealousy they may
be more likely to engage in rough sex
and in particular the rough sex was
actually just being rougher during the
sex act thrusting harder
um penetrating further what was
interesting about that is that the women
reported experiencing a shorter duration
to orgasm
when they engaged in that kind of sex so
I mean it could be rewarding for the
women because it's actually maybe extra
arousing maybe providing better
stimulation how did you study the that
we asked people we didn't right like
have them come into the lab and tell
them we want you to have sex like you
really you've got it you've got another
half an inch out of it though you've
done very well
yeah we did not do that although it
would be fabulous if somebody did do
that kind of study but no we did not we
were asking undergraduates so we did not
have them come in
engage in activities glad that you
didn't have to go through that why why
is it that there are so many varied
niches for porn and what turned people
on why are humans sexually not more
simple
yes there are lots of different genres
but there are also tremendous similarity
between genres like if you think about
the bodies of people in foreign the
majority of them are quite similar right
what we find attractive in men and women
is actually in that sense not that
variable I think where you see the
variation is in what I would call like
individual differences in people's
foreign preferences where people may
find
um
uh you know particular aspects of
individuals exciting or exotic they may
find different positions exciting and
exotic and there are also differences in
people and again we don't necessarily
know that much about what shapes them
but like impreferences for things like
say for example BDSM right so that you
have categories that are designed to
contain activities that will appeal
particularly people that are interested
in that and I mean PornHub is a great
example of that when they you know allow
you to choose from all of these
different types of drones do you want to
watch threesomes do you want to watch
um you know solos you know ones do you
want to watch BDSM do you want to watch
Dave do you want to watch straight do
you want to watch orgies like what is
your flavor of the month and they give
you that kind of opportunity to try that
variation and I think some people have
tried to make some little inroads into
figuring out what kinds of factors shape
some of these preferences
um a number of years ago
um Marianne Fisher and Becky Burch and I
published a study where we were looking
at how people's
[Music]
um
um sociosexuality as well as
um their inclinations towards infidelity
might shape their porn preferences and
looking at whether or not they were more
likely to
um you know prefer threesomes or
different kinds of orgy scenarios and we
did find small but significant
differences where people who had
actually scored higher on a measure of
inclination towards it in infidelity as
well as people who actually cheated on a
partner were more likely to like group
sex scenes in their porn they watch
those kinds of movies more often
interesting what about women like with
porn that seems to be just a big mystery
as far as I can see what what porn do
women watch they watch porn well they
don't watch as much porn as men do right
and again I think there's an interesting
question about whether there are
differences between women who prefer
their porn erotic or whatever you want
to call it they're sexually explicit
material to be visual versus they want
to read it right because there's tons of
um everything from romance novels to 50
Shades of Gray to all sorts of different
kinds of erotica to slash fiction online
I mean all of this stuff is all largely
directed you know towards women some of
it is very sexually explicit but it's
not visual in the same way so I think
the interesting questions in some ways
one of the interesting questions for me
about women is what what makes some
women more visually oriented and some
women more interested in reading about
their porn and it might be as simple as
like you know prenatal testosterone
exposure or adult circulating
testosterone it might be that women that
are slightly masculized in that way are
more visually oriented
um and so would prefer to watch it
rather than read about it but it's very
clear that lots of women are interested
in it and it just sort of tends to break
out into this difference between visual
versus
um written and
um a number of years ago I think I
reported in a study that was looking at
just you know top erotic sites that men
and women were going to online right and
so of course for men it was all visual
right the top five sites they had
millions of viewers you know all visual
for women none of the top ones were
visual they were all either like romance
novel
um authors websites harlequin's website
and then Archive of Our Own which is the
big fan fiction
um website and so they're reading their
porn I think more of them anyways are
reading their porn than watching it
for the last six years or so five or six
years I apart from during covid I have
gone to a uh
dark romance uh uh book convention uh in
America I spent a number of years on the
front cover of a bunch of these books
I've been flown out by authors and a few
other bits and pieces so my exposure to
this world is um deeper than you might
expect and given that
one of the questions I've always had in
the back of my mind is in a world that
is being dominated by Tick Tock and
YouTube and video consumption what are
women getting out of erotica
that they can't get out of video
hmm
I think well so I don't know that it's
necessarily
that they can't get it out of video
except that for the most part we're not
producing as much maybe that appeals to
them for various reasons
um but I think that they they I don't
think it's that they could not right I
mean if you think about
um movies that were erotic or romantic
in various ways that that women liked
Brokeback Mountain was a great example
of I mean women like Brokeback Mountain
women loved broke a mountain but it was
a romance and they've had two hot guys
and so you know there were a lot of
women that liked that movie
um and so I think
and women who wrote fan fiction about
that movie and so I think you can get it
out of the visual but part of the
problem is is again I think
for women
um a lot of what seems to go into and
this is one thing that books can do
better I think sometimes than than
visual media can is because so many
women and this is not all women it's not
all women all the time but because so
many of them part of what's interesting
to them about erotica and romance and
all this kind of stuff and sexual
relationships is the long-term
commitment aspect of things with their
ideal guy right
there's a lot more than the visual
that's important to that right there's
all this information about who he is and
who they imagine he might be
um and so yes you can do that in a movie
if you have a five hour movie or you can
you know watch Lord of the Rings and
imagine your context for one of the guys
or Marvel or whatever
but when you read a novel you get all of
that information so if you think about
erotic or romantic novels for women
they're partially a story about finding
long-term mates that are women's fantasy
partner
um I think that that's a lot easier to
do in a book that will appeal broadly
because you can the the story appeals to
most women
um the features of the individual men
and women in it or men and men or women
and women depending on your interests
um might be very unique to different
women like maybe you find a particular
actor attractive or you don't right and
so the movie might not work for you if
you just happen to not like maybe you're
somebody who doesn't like Brad Pitt so
watching him in a movie isn't going to
work for you
um but maybe Zac Efron will or whoever
right like there's going to be that
variability so I think there's more
challenges with the films than there
would be with stories although it's
interesting to take that and then say
well why is fan fiction so popular
because they have the image but of
course they select for guys that they
find attractive and then read fan
fiction that is about those characters
that look the way they want them to look
and then they can fantasize about those
kinds of relationships
um but I'd be curious actually in some
ways to know about your experience of
interacting with women at that kind of a
convention having been the cover model
because they often have quite
significant fantasies about those
characters and that must have been
interesting it was it's been interesting
old however five or six times that I've
been and then I I'm on another bunch of
covers and then I go back and I'm on
different books and
a different story and a different
character and different women come up
and say Hello uh it's very very
interesting I have to say my mum my mum
asked whether she could get a copy of
one of the books and I refused I refused
to give it to her
um because I don't think she quite knew
what she was getting herself in for and
given the fact that I was on the cover I
felt uh uncomfortable to say the least
about about passing that on that being
said the
the women that write because I am more
experienced around the authors than I'm
around the readers although most of the
authors are also fans of other people's
work uh they take the story writing
stuff very seriously and I mean these
books are they're best sellers across
the USA Today best sellers and all sorts
of stuff one thing that I thought as you
were talking there about why it is that
women prefer erotica I'm going to guess
that there are relatively few stories in
which the male protagonist gets switched
out multiple times because that would
reflect women's uh lower desire for
sexual variety so what that suggests is
that it isn't about the erotica bit of
erotica it's about the commitment of a
presumably high value High status
powerful man who is able to girdle the
world around him and break down doors
and do the things in order to get the
woman that he wants but if it was simply
about the erotica thing without the
investment without the long-term make
value stuff why why wouldn't each
chapter just be it was David and Matthew
and Jonathan and like why wouldn't she
just
precisely for this reason that it is
that investment yeah I mean I think that
you know when people say
more often so
mating strategy
this is also why there's a challenge
with pornography now that doesn't mean
that all women are always interested in
long-term mating and only reading about
that right so there are certainly women
who are going to enjoy pornography
um and they may be women who score
higher in sociosexuality right they may
be more interested in short-term mating
they may be in the Life phase when
they're more interested in short-term
mating and that might be something that
influences it I mean the other thing
that would be interesting and I haven't
seen anything where somebody's looked at
this would be to look at if you look at
pornhub's data it suggests that there
are actually differences in the
percentage of women that consume
pornography across countries
and it would be interesting to know if
that is about cultural acceptance or
whether it is actually about
you know differences in mating
strategies different kinds of
populations was it Indonesia or
somewhere that had a surprise
Philippines Philippines that was it yeah
had a surprisingly have you looked at
Seth Stevens davidowitz's work on this
he did uh everybody lies
so he's a data scientist he's a data
scientist you should you should
absolutely check it out it's fascinating
and he found out that there is uh the
highest proportion of breastfeeding porn
in the world is in India and it is
insane how much more there is it's like
a factor of 20 or something yeah that's
not that common in like American porn
consumption at all so I mean I think
that is really interesting because again
you always like are wondering okay what
does it that shapes it because
everything in India
yeah I mean there's there's all well
there's I mean maybe well I don't know I
don't even want to speculate about that
I mean I I've also seen interesting
stories about women in India
breastfeeding animals too it's much more
common there to see that if a small
animal is orphaned I
seeing not in their porn just in general
right I mean that they will breastfeed
you know cats that you know are rejected
by the mother or lose the mother which
is also in interesting right that you
would but I mean many people in India
actually sort of you know have sacred
views about cows so they're almost
they're almost human perhaps interesting
there's something going there's
definitely something going on with the
breasts yeah in India here's another
thing here's another thing that I've
considered more especially given my uh
deep experience with the dark romance
genre
the characteristics that I see on and I
at these events there's been thousands
of fans right and hundreds of author
stalls and I walk around and I have a
look at the stands and a lot of the time
they've got those pull-up banners and
the book covers and the photographers
are there that have taken them and every
single one of the guys that comes out
that I'll see some from Philadelphia and
some from Miami and whatever whatever
everyone's built the same right yes
everyone is strong Joe everybody's lean
everybody goes to the gym now there's
different you know this dude with long
hair there's a guy with a beard this guy
that's more like a lumberjack there's
one that's it whatever whatever right
at the moment it seems like a lot of
women are applauding significantly more
feminine men in popular culture ones
that are much more agreeable ones that
are much more submissive you had Harry
Styles being a sex icon wearing a dress
not long ago on the front cover of a
magazine
why aren't those sorts of guys there's
also just to add on there there's
another element
um the Gen Z Tick Tock sort of
almost uh androgynous not quite
androgynous look but super Femme guy at
18. in fact I think I saw a study very
recently that you may have seen as well
on Twitter that had the two highest
rated men on Tinder in the world one of
them look like the front cover of a dark
romance guy and the other one looked
like Harry Styles on the front of that
thing what is it that's causing erotica
to not have is it short short term
mating cues that doesn't seem right
because we've got this long-term
investment why is it that publicly we're
getting pushed a much more submissive
much more agreeable much more feminate
man and yet it seems in erotica like
reveal preferences stated preferences
why do they seem to be diverging
yeah I mean I think that in a sense you
kind of captured it with the pushing
aspect of it right like that there's
okay there is a there is a uh you know
there can be a social agenda and not
maybe wanting men or at least not
wanting some men to be more aggressive
um and we often see sort of like at
least recently sort of like negative
view of masculinity in general right
like this idea that well masculinity is
toxic or that you know men need to be
different
um which also doesn't really Jive well
with the view that some people have that
men and women are not different it's
like well if they're not different then
why are you worried about this aren't
you worried about toxic femininity
um I mean it is an interesting question
but I think that that you know uh as you
point out if if the point of that kind
of erotica is
to fulfill the fantasies of women the
fantasies of women are not about
generally men that they can push around
they're about men that are useful if the
world comes to an end
um it's it's the things that that
historically and ancestrally women
valued in men is he going to be a good
provider is he a good protector is he
gonna you know take care of my kids is
he gonna give my kids good genes that
are going to make them strong what would
you what would you say so the ideal of
the cover what would you say to the
women that are saying to you well
Catherine you know those are that's a
old Antiquated view of what women want
from men have we not transcended that
now in the new world you know I don't I
I'm perfectly happy if my boyfriend
decides to paint his nails and web holes
and and put a dress on this is this is
something now where I I don't think that
you're up with the times here sure I
mean I would say that you know whatever
floats your boat right like I mean if it
works for you
for your partner to be like that's also
perfectly fine there may be variation
between women and that but years ago
they really tried to push the
softer gentler Kinder view of guys in
romance novels and they didn't sell well
and my guess is they didn't sell well
because even if in your daily life it
might be easier to have a guy that would
do whatever you wanted no matter what
that might not be what you fantasize
about
right I mean if we think about what what
what is really appealing to us in the
same sense that of course you know men
may fantasize about women that they
would never get in real life
right if you think about the reality of
things if you're
an unattractive male who uh is older and
doesn't have any resources
you know you're not going to get the
average porn star but that doesn't mean
that that's not what floats your boat so
it is it is almost a kind of not so much
not short-term mating strategy thing but
it is an object of sexual desire that
may not match up with what you would
want as a long-term partner there may be
some differences there that women have
well mate might be what what you might
want but also might not be what you can
get right as well I think that that's
part of it because I think that every
girl who goes to a romance novel
convention would be happy to have one of
the cover models go on with her uh and
stay there
um but you know there are also you know
there are pros and cons to highly
masculine men right I mean and there's
often been this debate about
um you know when you look at at even the
hero in the romance novel I mean he's
very manly guy
um but there is that that issue is he a
cat or is he a dad and even when he
starts out as a cat he usually ends up
as a dad bad that's not always the way
it is in real life if if you find that
guy right so there's always going to be
that compromise of what are the features
that you would ideally like in your
day-to-day life and some of it may be
that some of it also maybe just what's
happening in the population right
there's always been this discussion
about whether testosterone levels have
decreased and that men actually are
somewhat less masculine than they used
to be in some ways and some of it may be
just like okay well this is what we have
and this is what we're going to work
with as well right
um so I think there's a number of things
I actually have to say I've never I've
never been a huge fan of the men with
their nails painted thing I don't know
why it just never seemed like something
I was particularly interested in but I
saw a guy who was an MMA fighter and he
had his nails painted he was still hot
even though his snails were painted if
you're an MMA fighter no one's allowed
to tell you that you're not hot in any
case exactly
here's the other thing right two two
worlds that fascinate me first off
erotica and and why it's not just all on
video or whatever second one true crime
the women why are they obsessed with
learning about murderers I would love to
see it I know the True Crime I think is
the single biggest podcast category that
that exists it's the number one society
and culture which is what this show is
in is the most competitive in terms of
shows volume of shows but in terms of
plays True Crime think about the first
one that ever came out that really broke
the entire world with this was serial
you've had up and vanished you've had
all of you know an endless list of them
and then all of the true crime
documentaries that you get that get
served to you on Netflix so and so forth
what is a woman's Obsession or women's
obsession with
crime and murderous stories
so that's an interesting question and
it's actually been
in particular
women
um because I'm interested in how pop
culture can be used to study
um uh you know human behavior and and
sort of our evolved psychology I'm I'm
particularly interested in why women are
so fascinated with serial killers right
in particular and you think about the
popularity of shows like Dexter and the
number of women that like really liked
that story and it's like
that's interesting because in general we
think of women as being very
crime-averse very crime avoidant try to
avoid people who are really violent
um and so there may be a number of
things going on I mean I think there may
be some truth to the idea that people
are fascinated with crime because they
want to learn how to avoid being victims
right that that can certainly be part of
it I think that for some women there may
also be a fascination with the idea of
some men being like the apex predator
right that if you are in a dangerous
environment what better man to have by
your side than the apex predator right
because nobody else is going to threaten
him or the things that that you know
belong to him
um I also think it's kind of interesting
because of course you know if you really
imagined
you know Dexter as a serial killer he's
not a very traditional serial killer
psychopath because of course he has
emotional attachments and things like
that and but maybe that's why he is so
extra appealing for women because they
want the Predator but he still has to be
devoted to her and those two things
often don't really go together but there
might be something very appealing about
imagining that they could
um so I mean I think part like I think
there may be dual functions like part of
it maybe the functionality of trying to
understand a phenomenon so well that you
are never the victim of it and some of
it may be that you know if you live in
the jungle you want the predator
to be with you and there is some data
that suggests that women that live in
more dangerous environments do prefer
more aggressive men like they have their
mate preferences shift a little bit
um I'm trying to remember might have
been
uh Dave Navarette and some of his
colleagues that did a study that that
looked at this so the women for example
who lived in more dangerous parts of
inner cities
valued if they were asked to Value
different traits valued physical prowess
and aggressiveness more in males but it
may be more useful to them in that
environment which again can also bring
us back to that issue about the
masculinity of males right if you live
in a really benign World maybe you don't
need some of those really aggressive
masculine traits as much as we might
have living on the Africa savannah or
early on during human history
um they may be less relevant today and
is it so I guess in that sense when we
think about May preferences I mean it's
not that they're fixed in stone forever
Revolution continues right
um and sexual selection continues and it
may be that at some point we live in
such a benign world that that
you know some of the masculine traits
that we've often admired
um that the women who go to boxing and
MMA clearly admire
um that those traits aren't as essential
in women's made preferences but I
suspect that the world probably isn't
going to get that benign because it does
seem to be sort of Shifting around a lot
right now spicy every so often yes
exactly this this is the interesting
thing about the uh proselytizing around
how feminine men that are most
submissive and agreeable would be
exactly the sort of man that I want to
be with it's that revealed versus stated
preferences thing again you know the
woman that do you remember when Tom
Holland uh and Zendaya announced that
they were in a relationship and she's
maybe five inches four inches taller
than him and it was a bunch of articles
that said it's now time for men to get
over their fear of tall women
yeah I mean come on now come on now
press come on now come on now it's it's
easier if you're Tom Holland too because
I mean he's fit he's got lots of
resources my point being that my point
being that the people that wrote those
articles that said it's time for me to
get over them will date a man that's
taller than them on average almost all
of them will be and the the evidence
seems to suggest uh women want to date a
man that's 21 centimeters taller than
them and men want to date a woman that's
16 centimeters shorter than they are so
you've got it everyone's got a
compromise right you can't have exactly
what you want my point being that there
is a uh especially when it comes to mate
Choice here because men tend to be the
sexual protagonists but women are The
Gatekeepers sometimes that gets flipped
and it gets put on men about what it is
that they're doing with regards to their
matrix it's like none of the short men
are not dating Zendaya they she hasn't
been turned down by reams of short men
up until she managed to find the one
that was prepared to get with her that
happens to be Tom Holland so yeah I
think yeah it's just interesting to see
as we have a mating crisis kind of
basically on our doorstep ever
increasing achievement
employment status for women less so for
men hypergamy kind of Shifting around
and doing all of this stuff
what what is being pushed in the press
and then what are those journalists who
are you dating are you dating the
homeless guy on the street are you
dating someone that's six inches shorter
than you and
I think just continuing to point out
that hypocrisy is really important
because sexual desires and what we think
we want gets mediated and filtered
through the culture right gets pushed
through like that and if the culture
ends up being a lap if what you think is
culture isn't because you only see the
smoke screen in front of you your own uh
sexual preferences can end up being
messed up which has were even further
Downstream consequences I think yeah if
men look if men look at an article that
says women really want effeminate guys
Harry Styles is the way to go and then
find very little success in the dating
market and I don't even know I don't
even know how a feminate Harry Styles is
in real life homeboy might be an
absolute stallion as soon as he gets
away from the the camera right right
yeah you don't know right you don't know
it all and so I mean I agree with you I
think and this is why you know I think
in general we should always be concerned
with what what is being pushed as the
main narrative in general right whether
it's a narrative in terms of of sexual
behavior and what people are doing or
what people want or what people should
want because I think that's part of it
as well right they're saying well you
should this is what you should want that
this is a better thing to want it's like
well well why right like I mean it's
like almost like you're saying it's
somebody's moral obligation
to date someone that may or may not be
what they find particularly attractive
um and I agree I mean it's problematic
if you're giving people advice that's
going to
um you know be detrimental to them in
finding what they really want
um and you know I think
it's relevant in that sense to to the
larger issues around dating but it's
also relevant to the incel issue you
know that that William solo talks about
um you know how do people know what the
best strategies are I mean to me I think
that that
people need to think a little bit about
you know it's not
so I mean as an evolutionary
psychologist I talk a lot about our
evolved strategies what was successful
in the past what has shaped the way we
are now that isn't to say that what
shaped Us in the past has to be what
shapes us a hundred thousand years from
now there could be reasons for things to
change but I don't know that we have
evidence that shifting things in any
particular direction is beneficial or
not
um you know it would be like saying well
we should have more masculine women men
should date more masculine women
you know it
why would that be a good or a bad thing
I mean in general it's good to find a
partner so maybe don't be so picky that
you priced yourself out of the market
across the board
um but people are attracted to what
they're attracted to and you know saying
that well you should find this
attractive
that that isn't going to make them find
that attractive unfortunately in most
cases right they're attracted to what
they're attracted to
the market and sexual desire are two
things that are very difficult to cheat
so in my experience this is the revealed
and stated preferences thing all over
again
um every year when love Island which is
this big reality TV show in the UK comes
on there is a body positivity and sexual
orientation and uh disability
orientation disability like um awareness
all a bunch of different groups say that
we don't have enough representation on
this show and you think well that's
maybe maybe that's a fair point there is
this many people in the country and this
many people and that's a percentage and
whatever whatever because well look
at the end of the day
this is the show that the designers of
the show have considered will be the
most effective if another one started up
that had different sorts of subcultures
within it and it did better than
fantastic the presumption is that it
won't so if that's the case if you
really cared about this then vote with
your eyes and go somewhere else and
watch something else the same thing goes
for which partner you're going to choose
which type of person it is that you're
going to be with you can say all you
want in your columns that you should
date short guys but if you don't go out
and do that what does it tell you about
your theory around whether or not guys
should get over their fear of tall women
or rich women or status for women or
whatever right like women aren't dating
younger men for that as another example
of that in terms of trying to open the
dating pool up so what I think kind of
an undertone that you can see here is
that evolutionary psychology could be
rather unpopular with quite a lot of
people I had Paige Harden on the show
about a year ago she wrote the genetic
Lottery Paige is interesting because she
comes from a left leaning background but
works in behavioral genetics which is
I mean that's chalk and cheese for you
there and she I see as she speaks that
she's battling with some of these
challenges talk to me about
evolutionary psychology as it relates to
feminism is evolutionary psychology
sexist can it be complementary of
feminism in any way do you think
I mean to me part of the problem and
part of why those fields I mean you have
people that argue that you can have
um you know a feminist evolutionary
psychology
um there are lots of people who argue
that it is sexist there's lots of people
who argue otherwise to me those those
terms and those definitions have become
so politics politicized to me they're
almost completely devoid from like
looking at the reality of people's
actual Behavior I mean what I don't even
know what it means to say that somebody
is sexist other than that somehow they
recognize that there are differences
between the Sexes now like that's become
sexist that men and women are different
and yet clearly they are otherwise
all the women would watch porn and all
the men would watch them would be at the
erotica Festival yeah yeah and they
they'd be you know reading romance
novels and again even if you say well
you know
maybe the people who go to the romance
uh conventions are just interested in in
looking at men so of course straight men
aren't going to do that
well the gay guys could all be going and
hanging out and reading the romance
novels they're not doing that either no
okay so like I mean I think at some very
basic level there are differences
between men and women they were shaped
by our evolutionary history it doesn't
mean that we're alien species but it
means that the problems that we face
that were different we evolved different
solutions to
me that you know I mean there are people
who will say that's sexist I mean to me
it's like well it's reality I mean I I
don't think that it's
um and I don't think that's good or bad
it's just the way it is I mean I guess
that's the problem so in a sense I'm
dodging I mean I suppose the question
because I don't so that's relevant that
would be that would be the Super recent
within the last half decade to decade
view of what sexism means but I think
that you could take a broader view maybe
over the last 30 to 40 Years Around
feminism and around
um preconceptions around women their
role in society what it is that they
want sensitive prescription them being
the ravished and needing a ravisher
stuff like that
um how how do you blend those two
together are they mutually incompatible
well I mean I think the some of the
sexual stereotypes that are involved in
that sort of thing like the idea that
women are always submissive I mean
people who
bought into that so we didn't interact
that much with women because even when
women are submissive they're often
running the show so it doesn't really
you know translate again very much into
the concreteness of things but I mean
here's my take on some of that with the
stereotypes I mean stereotypes come from
somewhere right they don't they weren't
just created by the culture I mean these
are things that were very common amongst
groups of people people make
generalizations about them they're not
true of every individual but they're
true of many individuals and so you know
I think that
um to the extent that evolutionary
psychology explores those things and is
interested in what makes
or shapes people yeah some of that data
is going to support things like that and
some of it's not the submissive one has
always been weird because it just seems
like
women the idea women and men do
different things and they may be
interested in different things and
people interpret that to mean sometimes
that women are this and men are that
that doesn't necessarily
you know imply submissiveness or
dominance
um
and there are women who want their man
to be I suppose submissive to them but
not submission to anybody else right
well that's and that's not precisely
precisely yeah that's the and I think uh
increasingly you're going to see the the
reversal of what you see publicly in
terms of the polarity of the bedroom is
a lot of the times what people feel
turns them on I think
you may see a lot more race play in the
bedroom
it's exactly the sort of thing that
you're not allowed to do when you're in
the real world it's the high-powered
Boss [ __ ] lawyer that wants to be tied
up at home right that's that's that it's
the reversal of what you're used to if
you ever watched um suits and there was
one of the guys in that and he used to
have this real rough sex thing and I
remember there was this scene and the
lady came up to him and she said
um uh what's the safe word that you've
chosen for for today and he said safe
words are for [ __ ] and the point
being he's this high-powered guy he's
got all of this control and in the
bedroom what does he do he completely
loses control yeah he completely passes
that off but I think you're going to see
some really weird quirks and and Kinks
come through now because of what is no
longer permitted like stuff like stuff
like race play I it would not surprise
me in the slightest if you're going to
see more stuff like that in the bedroom
yeah well I mean it would be interesting
to see I mean not that we get to see
everything from the bedroom I mean you
can ask people and and hope that they go
to China go to China they'll tell you
everything
but I do think that it might be
interesting if you see that reflected in
pornography because it used to be that
so much of pornography was controlled by
the big companies that made films now is
so much of it just being distributed
online and all the amateur stuff and
maybe we will see an uptick in like
interracial stuff and in particular
types of scenarios within those
combinations that you could imagine
would have been seen as taboo
um but I mean again if it's on the
internet and it's pornography you can
get away with a lot of those taboos
right
another thing that I looked at was the
differences in the chemicals emitted
from babies heads making men more docile
and women more aggressive if you looked
at that vaguely I saw something about
that I did not read the the actual
source of where it came from but I read
a story that was talking about that
which I thought was weird unless you
know part of it is about maybe women
if you know if they have babies need to
be more aggressive in the protection and
defense of their own and maybe sometimes
they're aggressive towards other
people's right if you think about it as
female competition right there's like in
other animal species sometimes females
are not very nice to other females
Offspring but you also have the aloe
parenting thing right as well so it
might cause women
right to become either like to become
more protective in the defense of their
children and other children within the
same group yes yes right yes rest for
men it should just make them all squishy
so they're all dads and so please do not
hit the child yeah do not damage it
don't try and swing it around in like
stop being such an idiot with it yeah
that makes sense there was another thing
I learned about will Costello told me
this the other night when we were out
for dinner
it's it's called like aggressive
cuteness or something where women are
like it's so cute I just want to squish
it like that kind of energy is actually
yes yeah it's a it's like it's a really
strange compulsion think about what that
is when it's this sort of overbearing
aggression but in a sort of a cutesy way
what is it that's causing the way that
this neotenous little blob to make
people do that it's such a weird thing I
agree with you that that's a weird thing
because I've never quite understood like
I mean I understand thinking things are
really cute and wanting to pick them up
and cuddle them but the idea of like
you're so cute I'm just gonna like grab
you that just seems to me to be
disturbing in a weird creepy way and so
yeah I don't know what is I mean I mean
I suppose some of it could just be like
intensity of reaction and not having
another outlet for it I mean women
pinching the cheeks of the child right
okay yeah I mean they also shriek a lot
sometimes too right sorry did you say
scientists did you see did you see that
study that just came out about
um why women scream when they see the
Beatles and bands and stuff no I didn't
see that right okay fans yes so it was
just like is was it focusing on
excitement or yes I'm going so I got it
sent by Rob Henderson earlier on
Thursday uh here it is uh why do female
fans scream for for the Beatles and
other Mega stars goes off the screen for
pop stars but why we still have a lot to
learn uh beetlemania blah blah blah blah
blah come on why scream for the Beatles
another Mega Stars this phenomenon is
attracted attention and Analysis from
popular press but relatively little
scientific Focus
come on what I mean how long does this
there it is if you've read some of my
posts in our Natural History you know
that screams both animal and human are
one of my research interests humans
share screams with many other animals
and these vocalizations are quite
conserved acoustically across even very
disparate species blah blah blah uh one
distinctive and common context for human
screens is pleasurable excitement as any
parent of a young child can attest to
children at swimming pools playgrounds
school bus stops and just about anywhere
they gather freely engage with one
another will scream this has not been
had much scientific research done on why
children scream like this and so whether
this tendency is truly species typical
and certain communicative perhaps even
adaptive functions is not well
established there is lots of evidence
though from mental health experts
despite the lack of scientific
understanding on the internet for
parents concerning embarrassing such
behaviors why they keep on screaming
why do they do it for the Beatles
although there is a lot of individual
variation with respects to Richard's
post sites as author Rachel Simmons who
contends that society's expectations of
politeness and modesty for young women
create pent-up energy for breaking out
of the constraining impulse rules and
Concepts represents such an opportunity
no doubt society's rules about
Conformity were far stricter in 1964
than they were today and yet fans of
Justin Bieber screamed today in much the
same way that the fans of The Beatles
did then side point I have a friend that
was a roadie at a some some sort of
Justin Bieber type thing and he said
that the sound at one of these is
absolutely deafening like
30 000 screaming teenagers and they've
got these industrial strength earplugs
that you use if you've got a jack hat if
you're one of those guys that works
eight hours a day on a jackhammer um
yeah screams attract attention are
likely contagious screaming like this
however is not restricted to popular
music icons is a much darker example
illustrates weren't a push 1913 to 1988
was a German politician in the Social
Democratic party Who as a Young Man
observed in a number of Nazi rallies
prior to the start of World War II he
was interviewed and provides accounts of
the events for this still remarkable
1973 documentary series The World At War
blah blah blah
basically it was propaganda tools they
were struck by the reaction of many of
the young women in attendance when
Hitler arrived at the festival he
described how the atmosphere grew more
and more hysterical he was interrupted
after nearly every phrase by big
Applause and uh women began screaming it
was like a mass religious ceremony at
first glance it is difficult to find any
similarities between a beloved music act
and a monstrous dictator why would both
elicit a similar response perhaps the
answers lies in the nature of the venue
which focuses the attention of large
crowds on individual figures that are
popular and influential Within These
crowds Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau has certainly elicited shrieks
and screams from young female fans the
Frantic and frenetic screaming at
concerts appears almost contagious
emotional contagion occurs in humans and
at least in some animals too represents
one dimension an explanation for this
sort of screaming is there anything else
in here emotional contagion is likely
only part of the explanation fans at
sports events cheer loudly but don't
scream a completely speculative
hypothesis this let's go derives from
some of my research on screams and the
literature on the evolution of these
vocalizations first and foremost screams
attract attention this is true across
the various species that scream that
tension might be from an ally such as a
close relative when a monkey or ape
screams in a fight or in other species
the scream might draw attention and
attract others when the caller is a
rabbit or other prey in the jaws of a
predator blah blah blah Rachel Simmons
who also views Fran screaming is
competitive but more in the sense that
young women are signaling to one another
their allegiance and passion for the
band she suggests it's a group bonding
phenomenon but that does not explain why
the fans don't tend to show such
exuberance with highly popular female
performers oh dear or why they don't
simply cheer loudly so that leaves us
with the hypothesis that competitive
screams are functioning in an arena
governed by sexual selection but shaped
by the particular cultural context of
mass Gatherings concerts and the
presence of a superstar look at me is
the message just as it is the message of
attention get getting screams of
children the phenomenon shows the
complexity of Screams as a mode of human
communication and how much more we still
have to learn about them
yeah that makes me think of girls at
concerts you know or other kinds of
events but in particular concerts
screaming and then lifting up their
shirts
right it very much is the look at me
aspect of it right
I mean I think that is part of it it's
like
you know it's somebody they find ideal
in whatever way
um I'm over here I'm over here yeah you
can hear me you can see me yeah
exactly
um you know I never really I mean it
definitely I mean the idea that it's
attention getting I mean it clearly
functions that way across feces but the
idea that one does it to draw attention
to you yourself when it's somebody that
you find sexually appealing also seems
to make a lot of sense and I don't think
it's just exclusive to things like that
I remember going to pro wrestling events
back in like the 90s the 80s and 90s and
in particular in that late late 90s
Attitude Era
I remember one they used to show a lot
more stuff on television back then too
because you know then the sensors got
really fussy about things again there
were a lot of women who would pull their
shirts up and have written on their
breasts the like logo or the nickname or
the initials of the guy that they liked
that was the wrestler and maybe they are
like screaming with their hands above
their head and their shirt like half
covering their face in some cases it was
a simpler time it was a simpler time
wasn't it yeah we could get you well you
could get your breasts out on television
and no one would say otherwise and
nobody thought it was weird wow I don't
know probably some people thought it was
weird yeah but it was definitely a
different time
Catherine Simon ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
things that you do where should they go
oh
edu and find me there
um
and I also if they're inclined to hunt
down academic papers researchgate is the
best way they can also email me at
Catherine underscore salmon.redlin or at
redlands.edu and I'm happy to respond to
interested
questions Catherine I appreciate you
thank you thanks very much what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]